this week we have a video question from
reader Jonathan Moore
what does unlocking a mobile phone and
tell and what benefits does unlocking it
confirm in the u.s. many phones are
locks to a specific carrier meaning
can't just pop in another SIM card and
get service unlocking the phone is a
software process that allows it to work
on other compatible carriers so let's
say you bought a phone through a teen
and wanting to get it working on
t-mobile unlocking it would let you do
that it can be extremely helpful when
traveling overseas if your phone is
unlocked and it has the right
requirements you can take it to another
country pop in another SIM card and get
local service there that can be much
cheaper than paying high international
rates but there has been a lot of
controversy over unlocking in the past
year after the Library of Congress a
government department that oversees
digital copyright matters deemed phone
unlocking illegal last year consumers
with the help of the White House fought
back in February the House repealed the
mandate the matter now sits with the
Senate consumers can typically bring
their phone to a carrier to have them
unlocked at least once their contract is
up 18 C actually lists the requirements
on their site attempting to unlock a
phone yourself though can result in
voiding the warranty and a host of other
troubles at least until the law is
overturned we want to hear more of your
good questions send them to us on
Twitter and Facebook with the hashtag
ask wsj d or email us at personal tech
at wsj.com